questo è un invito a un viaggio un
viaggio meraviglioso nella più alta
cultura accademica internazionale
il viaggio è gratuito
gli unici requisiti sono curiosità e
desiderio di apprendere questo viaggio è
possibile grazie a una rivoluzione che
ha trasformato radicalmente e che nei
prossimi anni stravolgerà il panorama
universitario mondiale la rivoluzione si
chiama mood un acronimo un po buffo che
sta permessi
open online courses corsi aperti in rete
per grandi numeri di studenti studenti
di tutte le età di tutti gli interessi
di tutte le generazioni
questa rivoluzione è cominciata quattro
anni fa con il lancio del primo book di
stanford sull'intelligenza artificiale
160 mila studenti hanno frequentato
questo primo corso è di la valanga
questo fenomeno si è andato espandendo a
partire da tre grandi aggregatori
americani si chiamano corsera helix e
iva city e poi sono arrivati anche gli
altri
poi vedremo la risposta e francesi degli
inglesi è quella nostra degli italiani
per darvi una dimensione del fenomeno
ad oggi abbiamo oltre 40 milioni di
studenti sui corsi book più di 4000
corsi universitari e tutto questo
naturalmente significa significa molte
cose
significa che le università possono
ancora svolgere e svolgeranno un ruolo
importantissimo solo nella misura in cui
si apriranno sempre di più alle nuove
dinamiche comunicative
perché se passiamo tre quarti della
nostra vita
e i nostri figli ei nostri nipoti non ne
parliamo sempre di più con questi
aggeggi è impensabile che lo studio
universitario si continui a fare come
duecento anni fa
questa è la chiave principale un modo di
entrare nelle nuove dinamiche cognitive
delle generazioni digitali
però poi c'è un altro aspetto molto
importante è l'aspetto che ci interessa
di più la qualità in sono diventati così
rapidamente così importanti perché
offrono a tutti il meglio perché i
migliori docenti del mondo insegnano
liberamente per chi abbia voglia di
apprendere
vedremo poi nella seconda parte c'è
qualche resistenza mi potete immaginare
c'è qualcuno che vorrebbe che le cose
restassero come sono sempre state ma la
spinta enorme ed è una spinta che viene
dall occidente ma viene anche come
potete immaginare dal resto del mondo
come si formeranno decine e decine di
milioni di cinesi gli indiani nei
prossimi anni
a quali università si scriverà è una
partita dalla quale non si può restare
fuori
io ho avuto la fortuna e la
testardaggine di dirigere ormai da dieci
anni quello che oggi è il più avanzato
progetto di learning piattaforma
ma di learning in italia si chiama
federica punto è un federica l'abbia
chiamata così perché ci piace l'idea che
quel signore con la barba che svariati
secoli fa fondò la federico ii si
chiamava così adesso si rivolgesse al
mondo con l'anima femminile più curiosa
più leggiadra più viva che appunto
federica federica oggi è la principale
piattaforma in italia e in europa
se mettiamo da fuori gli inglesi si sono
messi fuori da loro perché poi ci hanno
una cosa interessante poi ne parleremo
ed è lo show lo importante per i corsi
che presenta e poi ne parleremo un
attimo dopo
ma è bellissima perché noi abbiamo
un'idea che qui in italia siamo nel
paese più bello del mondo
siamo famosi in tutto il mondo per il
design e se stiamo ricostruendo le aule
in cui bisognerà studiare per i prossimi
decenni noi vogliamo che queste aule
siano bellissime ed è quello che vi
faccio vedere adesso un attimo insieme
rosina is back
alla velocità della luce
l'incontro tra le culture del mondo
grazie ad internet è a portata di click
nell'universo del cyberspazio le aule
sono senza confini
welcome to federica l'università
pubblica gratis a casa tua
a tu per tu con i tuoi docenti da anche
nel 1300 effetto ha scritto un testo ha
parlato di argomenti di problemi è stata
l'altra che stonano severino sa
distinguere tra le persone favorevoli e
quelle contrari all'oggetto con noi
stiamo studiando il fallimento abbiamo
esordito nella prima unità dicendo che
luogo degli uccelli come anche quello
dei rettili un uomo
l'iphone è tutto evidente che a rischio
di influenzare l'opinione pubblica
attraverso la pubblicazione dei sondaggi
ha venduto le ss jonica tegola moda e
rigida c'è per allungarla un po devo dì
l'area molto forte la politica adesso
stato albero verde è qualcosa di più e
qualche corsa a colori la politica del
technicolor come rompere
dopo aver ascoltato i video
spogli ai testi delle elezioni leggi con
attenzione poi ripassare i video mentre
approfondisce gli argomenti l'ambiente
didattico ideale per la nuova
generazione digitale
la tua lezione in presa diretta
testi e video insieme a tua disposizione
navigami la straordinaria ricchezza e
varietà di risorse selezionate dal tuo
docente
sottolinea i passaggi chiave mettili tra
i tuoi appunti condividilo con i tuoi
compagni
tieni d'occhio i tuoi progressi
su federica il mood parlano finalmente
italiano il nuovo formato didattico che
sta rivoluzionando l'insegnamento
universitario diventa un prodotto made
in italy grazie a un grande ateneo
italiano su una piattaforma italiana
con la cura del dettaglio e il senso del
bello che il mondo riconosce all'italia
unisciti a noi su federica a tutto mucca
allora queste ceneri che basta andare su
google e scrivere federica punto è e ci
trovate se scrivete solo federica
trovate alla piattaforma premium dove ci
sono comunque 300 corsi ma senza il
video e questa è l'evoluzione della
specie sarebbe federica sapiens o
perlomeno federica videns se volete
perché no il problema
vedete è tenere insieme queste due parti
e tenere insieme la dinamica del video
con la quale dobbiamo comunque fare i
conti perché perché più forte di noi
però come vedrete su federica ci sono
sempre i testi a corredo ci sono le
fonti io dico sempre noi non facciamo i
loro animi noi facciamo il web riding
perché in rete c'è l'ira di dio in rete
c'è tutto io la chiamo l'arc sandra
elettronica il sogno che abbiamo avuto
per millenni suoni corso di federica
trovate almeno 150 link a fonti
autorevoli al libri libri interi o le
recensioni o le biografie o altri video
di approfondimento
insomma un formato didattico al passo
con la nostra vita
federica è la piattaforma più importante
che c'è in italia di gran lunga grazie
ai fondi europei che l'hanno reso
possibile si parla spesso male di questi
fondi europei non è vero quando si ha un
buon progetto arrivano i fondi e se si
spendono bene federica è fatto
soprattutto da donne giovani
professioniste multimediali è un
progetto d'avanguardia in europa e sta
crescendo molto rapidamente
non ci sono solo docenti della federico
ii ci sono docenti di altri atenei anche
internazionali e stiamo moltiplicando
l'offerta
noi ci auguriamo che possa crescere
sempre di più e ci sono le premesse
perché questo succeda naturalmente
bisogna crederci in tanti e bisogna come
dire non lasciarsi colonizzare perché il
rischio è serio nel momento in cui le
università americane con i numeri che vi
ho detto
entrano in campo il rischio che si vada
tutti a stanford senza i 40 mila dollari
che ci vogliono adesso magari solo 4mila
c'è
e visto che noi abbiamo invece una
straordinaria produzione culturale in
questo prezzo visto che possiamo essere
noi attrattori anche dei giovani dei
giovani migliori su federica uno dei
miei sogni e di mettere insieme tutti i
vincitori d arcy che sono i progetti più
competitivi vincere unirsi junior
significa entrare di corsa nella
carriera universitaria
immaginatevi avere questi ce n'è uno
andatevelo a vedere latino della
partoriente quando si parlava latino per
quattro secoli siamo stati noi
il bilinguismo del mondo e fatevi un
giro ripeto non ci si deve nemmeno e
scrivere per vedersi trailer e la prima
lezione
l'iscrizione è comunque gratuita e ci fa
piacere se la fatte perché così entriamo
in contatto con voi ci mandate feedback
le critiche guardatevi il corso di
sociologia della povertà è bellissimo
oppure robotics foundation è uno dei
massimi esperti internazionali oppure se
vi interessa la politica vi consiglio
politico globale
anche perché docente che lo insegno in
francese sottotitolato in inglese è
meglio di clooney dal punto di vista
della
capacità scenica e anche questo come si
dice aiuta questo video lo trovate nella
home page nella home page di federica
dott
c'è anche quattro sezioni di blog per
coloro che vogliono capire cosa sta
succedendo perché sta succedendo di
tutto ed è straordinaria l'opportunità
che si sta aprendo per tutti noi e in un
paese come l'italia dove tre settimane
fa sul corriere della sera due pagine di
federico fubini ci hanno spiegato che
siamo diventati il fanalino di coda
dell'europa nella classe d'età 25 34
siamo al 24 per cento di laureati la
media ue e 33 francia spagna polonia
sono al 46 è una vergogna
questo è un paese che si sta condannando
allontana sia ma scusate ma dove saremo
fra vent'anni con questi tassi di
istruzione terziaria allora se si può e
si può rispondere non mettendoci a
costruire università di serie c in giro
per il paese che ci vogliono dieci anni
per accontentare cento baroni ma con la
migliore cultura accademica
internazionale
dico io facciamo né soprattutto dico si
può si può veramente fare web con
federica
grazie